[Music]
it is rare for a 15-year-old to be
singing churchill opera in singapore
because of my young age the adults that
performed to opera adopt me
they think is she too young to perform
such a character or is she able to
perform it well or she just doing it for
fun
[Music]
tissue opera is a traditional art form
that has been around for hundreds of
years
out of all the other chinese operas it's
the only opera that use the voice box
and the power of the diaphragm to sing
the other operas uses mostly the
falsetto thing
i come from tiju family and at the age
of two plus my grandmother brought me to
churchill opera performances i started
to perform at the age of three
my first time doing a full-length
tutorial show there were many many
people in the company that would say is
someone as young as her able to pick up
such an important role that has so many
scenes i practice almost every day
i go to nanyang girls high school and
sometimes the practice sessions might be
after school there have been instances
where i have to sleep at 2am in the
morning because i have schoolwork that
has to be done
[Music]
i've traveled to numerous countries for
performances i didn't expect that out
become so noticeable in such a short
period of time my initial intention was
to just do something that i love
today juju opera is considered as a
dying art the audience is mainly the
older generation it's not being passed
down to younger generations i want to
work harder so that the audience will be
attracted and come back for the next
performance i want the future
generations to remember their roots and
to see something as beautiful as studio
opera
[Music]
you